For most cats, catnip is like crack.
But what is it that makes them go so crazy?
And is it JUST cats who are affected by it?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and those
of you out there who own cats have probably,
at some point, gone to the pet store and purchased
catnip.
They love it, right?
At the time, you probably didn’t give it
much thought - but realize that every time
you give your cat catnip, you’re actually
dosing them with a psychoactive drug.
It’s like weed for cats, basically.
So how does it work?
And why do cats go SO crazy for it?
Well, the proper name for catnip is Nepeta
cataria.
It’s part of the mint family, but it’s
special - because the entire plant is coated
in these tiny microscopic bulbs that contain
a chemical called nepetalactone, which gets
released whenever those bulbs rupture.
And that chemical is what draws cats to the
plant.
When they inhale it, it binds to the receptors
in their nose, and stimulates neurons that
lead to their brain, altering several key
areas - including the hypothalamus, which
is the part of the brain that regulates emotions.
Essentially, it triggers a reaction that makes
cats feel intoxicated and euphoric.
Similar to how humans feel when they take
certain drugs.
The key difference though, is that all humans
respond differently to various drugs - whereas
cats have a very predictable and consistent
response to catnip.
When they smell it, they all react pretty
much the same way.
That said, there is a subset of the feline
population that appears to be immune to the
effects of catnip.
It’s estimated that around 20-30% of cats
don’t react to it at all, but the ones who
do - react the same.
There’s basically no in-between.
So it’s theorized that this is some kind
of genetic trait that gets passed down.
Which makes sense, since a lot of wild cat
breeds - like lions and tigers - are also
affected by it.
But what about humans?
Can we feel the effects of catnip?
Well, believe it or not - humans have been
using catnip off and on for the past 400 years.
In the 1600s, Europeans brewed tea with it,
made juice out of it, and even smoked or chewed
it - claiming that it produced a mild sedative
effect.
It was also believed to be a cure for colic
in babies, for a short time.
As recently as the 1960s, some people even
used it as a substitute for marijuana, saying
that it caused hallucinations and euphoria
- although scientists eventually debunked
that.
Their hypothesis was that it can’t affect
us as intensely as it does cats, because our
brains and olfactory systems - what we use
to smell - are structured very differently.
But that doesn’t mean catnip doesn’t have
ANY benefits for humans.
Also in the 1960s, researchers WERE able to
find one clear-cut use of it: as a mosquito
repellent.
Apparently, the active chemical in catnip
also works as a natural repellent to mosquitos,
and is actually MORE effective than DEET.
The only problem is, it wears off much more
quickly.
Still, you can totally find supplements online
that contain catnip essence, as well as others.
So if you’re one of those people who doesn’t
like using harsh chemicals - then you may
wanna give it a try.
What do you guys think?
Especially those of you with cats - are they
down with ‘nip, or do they not care at all?
You can let us know your answers in the comments
below - otherwise, thanks for watching!